Life is fundamentally different from dead stuff,
or is it physicists to ER, find life this way?
Living things avoid decay into disorder and equilibrium.
What does this mean? Let's pretend the chore download folder is the universe.
It started orderly and got more and more chaotic over time.
By investing energy, you can create order and clean it up.
This is what living things do, but what is life?
Every living thing on this planet is made of cells.
Basically a cell is a protein based robot,
too small to feel or experience anything.
It has the properties we just assigned to life.
It has a wall that separates it from the surroundings, creating order.
It regulates itself and maintains a constant state.
It eats stuff to stay alive. It grows and develops.
It reacts to the,
and its subject to evolution and it makes more of itself.
But of all the stuff that makes up a cell, no part is alive. Stuff,
reacts chemically with other stuff,
forming reactions that start other reactions,
which start other reactions in a single cell. Every second,
several million chemical reactions take place, forming a complex orchestra.
A cell can build several thousand types of protein, some very simple,
some complex micro machines.
Imagine driving a car at 100 kilometers an hour while constantly rebuilding
every single part of it with stuff you collect from the street.
That is what cells do, but no part of the cell is alive.
Everything is dead matter. Moved by the laws of the universe.
So is life the aggregate of all these reaction processes that are taking place.
Eventually every living thing will die.
The goal of the whole process is to prevent this by producing new entities.
And by this we mean DNA. Life is in a way,
just a lot of stuff that carries genetic information around.
Every living thing is subject to evolution and the DNA that develops the best
living thing around it will stay in the game. So is DNA life.
Then if you take DNA out of its whole,
it's certain is a very complex molecule, but it can't do anything by itself.
This is where viruses make everything more complicated.
They are basically strings of RNA or DNA in a small hu and need
cells to do something.
We are not sure if they count as living or dead. And still there are
225 million cubic meters of viruses on earth.
They don't seem to care what we think of them.
There are even viruses that invade dead cells and reanimate them.
So they can be a host for them,
which blurs the line even more or mitochondria.
They are the power plants of most complex cells and were previously free living
bacteria that entered a partnership with bigger cells.
They still have their own DNA and can multiply on their own,
but they are not alive anymore. They are dead.
So they traded their own life for the survival of their DNA,
which means living things can evolve into dead things as long as it's beneficial
to their genetic code.
So maybe life is information that manages to ensure its continued
existence. But what about AI?
Artificial intelligence by our most common definit,
we are very close to creating artificial life in computers.
It's just a question of time before the technology we build gets there.
And this is not science fiction either.
There are a lot of smart people actively working on this.
You could already argue that computer viruses are alive. Hmm. Okay.
So what is life? The then things,
processes DNA information.
This got confusing very fast. One thing is for sure,
the idea that knife is fundamentally different from non-living things because
they contain some nonphysical element or are governed by different principles
than inanimate objects to turns out to be wrong.
Before Charles Darwin humans drew a line between themselves and the rest of
living things, there was something magical about us that made us special.
Once we had to accept, we are like every living, being a product of evolution,
we drew a different line,
but the more we learn about what computers can and how life works,
the closer we get to creating the first machine that fits our description of
life.
The more our image of ourselves is in danger again,
and this will happen sooner or later. And here's another question for you.
If everything in the universe is made of the same stuff,
does this mean everything in the universe is dead or all that?
Everything in the universe is alive.
That it's just a question of complexity. Does this mean we can never die?
Because we were never alive in the first place is life and death and a relevant
question. And we haven't noticed it yet. Is it possible?
We are much more part of the universe around us than we thought.
Don't look at us. We don't to have any answers for you.
Just questions for you to think about after all it's thinking about questions
like this, that makes us feel alive and gives us some comfort.
So.